it was September of 2003 Andy jasse was
nervous he had an idea that had been
percolating in his mind for over a year
simply put Andy thought Amazon should
build and sell digital infrastructure to
third parties but he was one of the few
who understood the business opportunity
Andy knew that if he didn't convince
Jeff Bezos and the rest of the senior
leadership team it wouldn't just be a
step backwards for his career at the
company Amazon would miss out on a
massive Market he made his pitch and
just like that Jeff Bezos approved it
right then and there neither man knew it
at the time but they just started a
business which 20 years later is worth
more than a trillion dollars this is the
story of how Andy ji Jeff Bezos and the
rest of Amazon discovered one of the
biggest markets in history this is the
story of Amazon web
services AWS is one of the most
revolutionary ideas in the history of
tech and it's arguably the most
successful second act for any major tech
company today the world's biggest
companies rely on AWS for everything
from their storage and Compu to their
payroll in crms and an entire generation
of amazing startups that form the fabric
of our everyday lives names like uber
Netflix Airbnb all owe their existence
to AWS it's not just startups either
Nasa uses AWS the literal CIA uses AWS
the history of AWS is a history of the
ways Computing and software development
and even capitalism itself have evolved
over the last 20 years and that's
important so maybe it isn't a surprise
that the origin story is pretty
complicated the main reason is that it's
just plain complex
especially for people who don't
understand software and that lack of
society-wide understanding has allowed
some false narratives to emerge for
example there's a theory that Jeff Bezos
and other senior people at Amazon got
the idea for AWS because they wanted to
make extra money renting out excess
server capacity it's true that Jeff
Bezos was annoyed at how much Amazon was
paying for Server costs but back then
almost 20 years ago it wasn't possible
to rent out capacity like it was a
storage locker another reason why the
origin story of AWS is so complex is
that it's hard to get a real sense of
what goes on behind the scenes at Amazon
so you need to kind of piece it together
from secondary sources but the main
reason AWS has such complex Origins is
because of the nature of innovation
itself we love stories about individual
Founders who came up with world changing
ideas on their own and then built
incredible companies but a lot of the
time especially within large
organizations that's not how it works
don't get me wrong Jeff Bezos and Andy
jasse are incredibly important people in
the history of AWS probably the two most
important people it just doesn't happen
without either of them but they didn't
invent the concept of AWS the truth is
no one person did it was the culmination
of dozens probably hundreds of memos
meetings and random conversations Jeff
and Andy's main contributions were in
seeing the big picture of what Amazon
was trying to do nurturing the good
ideas and then maintaining a laser-like
focus on execution that doesn't make
their contributions less important and
it doesn't make the story of AWS any
less exciting in fact I think it's the
opposite Amazon created a AWS because it
was the only company in the world that
could there's an irony here throughout
the development of AWS Amazon's leaders
were obsessed with building something
that could be used by kids working on a
project in their dorm room but they also
wanted it to be so scalable that when
those kids turned into Mark Zuckerberg
or Patrick hollison they would stick
with AWS like I said AWS has a
complicated backstory but that doesn't
mean we can't tell the story from the
beginning to begin let's rewind a little
a few years before Andy jasse made his
pitch to Amazon's s team it was the late
1990s and Amazon had a problem it didn't
look like it from the outside sales for
axed between 1997 and 1998 Amazon was
adding new features almost every day and
hiring tons of Engineers but that insane
growth was precisely the problem
basically Amazon was suffering from
success internally the company was
running on what at the time was a
traditional two-tier architecture on the
one side you had a monolithic
application that served the pages on the
website then on the other side you had a
bunch of different databases That Grew
with every new customer product category
and Market that architecture was
basically fine when Amazon was a small
online book seller but as Amazon
expanded that system increasingly
struggled to cope the end result was
like a Jenga Tower one wrong move or one
new feature that wasn't properly
implemented and everything could topple
over it was a big mess that created tons
of redundancy and those architectural
constraints created real business
constraints Jeff Bezos didn't want to
just sell books he wanted Amazon to
become the everything store this problem
came to a head when Amazon was hired by
their competitors the large physical
retailers like Walmart and Target to
build out their e-commerce platforms
I'll let Andy Jesse explained there were
a few things going on I'll call it
between the years 2000 and 2003 that
made us think this could be a good idea
you know the first was this business in
Amazon called merchant.com where we sold
our third our e-commerce technology at
third party Merchants these are
companies like Target marks and Spencer
and when we went to deliver that
solution to those companies it turned
out to be way harder and way more timec
consuming than any of us imagined and
that's because we had uh really kind of
jumbled up a bunch of parts of our
platform growing as fast we did the
first eight years and to deliver these
through apis which is the way that these
companies wanted to consume them it took
a lot of decoupling and a lot of work
that we just hadn't thought about before
jasse and Bezos knew that the Legacy
architecture put a hard limit on
Amazon's future in fact it was already
eating into its margins and because
Amazon was so far ahead of its
competitors there weren't many real life
examples of how to solve this problem
they couldn't just pick a solution off
the shelf they pretty much had to invent
one so that's what they proceeded to do
back in 1998 a team of Amazon Engineers
wrote something they called the
distributed computing Manifesto at this
stage I should stress something the
creation of AWS was a deeply
collaborative Endeavor dozens probably
hundreds of people were involved but
there are memos and moments and people
which I'll talk about in this video that
really matter the distributed computing
Manifesto is one of those memos that
really matters and just over 3,000 words
the authors did three things firstly
they identified the flaws in Amazon's
existing two-tiered architecture
secondly they proposed a different
architecture model to replace it and
then last but not least they described
the change in mindset that needed to
accompany the technical changes for the
shift to work the model proposed in the
manifesto was what's called a service
oriented architecture or S SOA in
software a service is something that's
designed to complete a specific task
like executing an operation or
retrieving some information in the case
of Amazon it might have been something
like fulfilling an order or delivering
it to the customer services allow
different business functions to be
performed remotely and independently in
other words they're modular and flexible
ideal for a company that wants to scale
quickly s SOA is just the name for all
those different Services working
together if that still doesn't make a
whole lot of sense don't worry here's an
analogy for Amazon transitioning to
service oriented architecture was like
going from building on top of a Jenga
Tower to building with Lego blocks Jenga
was delicate and fragile any new feature
or change to an existing feature and the
whole thing could collapse but Lego is
different the blocks fit together
perfectly they're reusable and they're
almost impossible to break the
distributed computing Manifesto was a
blueprint for a different kind of
company it would go on to influence Jeff
bezos's thinking as he considered how to
modernize Amazon's architecture he met
with people who urged him to embrace
apis as a way of opening Amazon to
outside developers he had long
conversations with his most trusted
employees including Andy jasse he read
books about architecture design and then
after months of absorbing advice and
information Bezos made a call it was
time to take a hammer to the existing
monolithic architecture it was time to
embrace s SOA Bezos knew it would be one
of the biggest leadership challenges of
his career because it's no exaggeration
to say it could make the difference
between Amazon being a trillion dooll
company or just another internet
retailer Lost In The Mists of time the
distributed computing Manifesto is an
important document in Amazon's Journey
from a monolithic architecture to
building AWS except it was more of a
mandate here's what it said all teams
will henceforth expose their data and
functionality through service interfaces
teams must communicate with each other
through these interfaces all service
interfaces without exception must be
designed from the ground up to be
externalizable anyone who doesn't do
this will be fired I'm pretty sure
that's not the actual text of the memo
Amazon has never released it and as far
as I know Jeff Bezos has never
acknowledged it the reason we know it
exists is because of a mistake Steve Y
is an engineer who's worked at senior
roles across Amazon Google and grab but
to the public he's best known for
accidentally publishing an internal
Google+ memo in October of 2011 in the
post which was mostly criticizing Google
yay talks about the Bezos memo he talks
about how it was a major turning point
in Jeff bezos's thinking about Amazon's
architecture which therefore makes it a
pivotal moment in the history of AWS so
let's break it down what does it mean
and why does it matter okay so the first
thing to understand is that when Bezos
was talking about service interfaces he
was talking that apis very quick hyper
simplified crash course an API or
application programming interface is a
mechanism that allows two different
software components to talk to each
other according to set rules for example
whenever you open the Weather app on
your phone it pulls the current data
from the weather bureau's Software
System using an API for Amazon customer
facing apis help to do things like
create rankings offer customer
recommendations and retriev save
customer details they're like Lego
blocks small modular unbreakable Bezos
believed apis the way forward for Amazon
he' even created a team within Amazon
whose sole purpose was creating them to
share with thirdparty developers that
led directly to incorporating apis into
merchant.com almost immediately
developers came up with innovative ways
to display the product catalog on their
sites those advances and the progress
that Amazon was making building apis
inspired Bezos to go a step further he
figured that if Amazon could build a
solution like that and transition from
its monolithic architecture to service
oriented architecture maybe the company
itself should follow the same same
pattern think about how profound a
change this was as yay pointed out in
his accidentally public memo organizing
into Services taught teams not to trust
each other in most of the same ways
they're not supposed to trust external
developers it sounds completely
counterintuitive but it was precisely
the lack of trust that made it work all
of a sudden every team within Amazon had
to interact using these so-called
hardened interfaces if you were HR and
needed some numbers from the marketing
department guess what you had to build
an interface to retrieve the numbers it
was a totally scalable decentralized
system hundreds of individual Lego
blocks once you truly understand the
implications of what Bezos was trying to
do you realized that he was shifting
Amazon onto the path that culminated
with the creation of AWS one of the best
decisions Amazon made right around this
time was hiring Alan verin ver Mulan
wound up becoming Amazon's CTO but his
first job was to build tools that
disentangled Amazon's messy code base
and separated it into hardened
interfaces that individual teams could
incorporate into their work without
without worrying if they were going to
break everything there's a term in
software engineering known as Conway's
law in its general form it says that the
technical infrastructure you build will
mirror the structure of your
organization I don't know if Jeff Bezos
knew about Conway's law he probably did
he's a smart guy either way he was
enacting Conway's law within Amazon in
July 2002 a couple years after Alan
verin was hired Amazon held a developer
conference today Amazon's reinvent
conferences are attended by thousands
and watched by millions but just eight
people attended the conference where
Amazon announced the launch of their new
division Amazon web services needless to
say it was nowhere near the AWS we know
today it was really just a way for
outside developers to access the
amazon.com product catalog still it was
an indication that something big was
beginning to happen developer
conferences were cool but Amazon had
bigger fish to fry this is the part of
the AWS story where Andy jasse becomes
more prominent so let's talk about him
for for a minute today Andy is Amazon's
CEO but despite rising to the top of one
of the world's biggest tech companies
he's not a software engineer he's a
Harvard NBA who's so obsessed with
sports he almost became a sports caster
in another world he's giving color
commentary on ESPN thankfully for
everyone except Amazon's competitors he
decided on a more conventional career
path Andy joined Amazon's marketing
department way back in 1997 after the
department was downsized in the wake of
the dotom crash Bezos appointed Andy to
be his shadow a hybrid role which was
part technical assistant part Chief of
Staff it was a strong signal to everyone
that Andy was a rising star now it was
his turn to prove it remember Amazon was
focused on rapid growth and that
presented new challenges for example
Amazon wanted to start selling clothes
but clothes aren't the same as books
books are almost perfect Commodities but
clothes aren't they come in different
sizes and colors in order to sell
clothes Amazon's Engineers people like
Alan ver Mulan had to build all kinds of
new features a bigger product catalog
and more website traffic meant
amazon.com needed more Community
features like username verification and
review ratings but those features
weren't being added as quickly as they
should have been Andy realized that the
reason projects were taking so long was
because software Engineers time was
constantly being consumed by doing work
that wasn't directly related to the
feature they were building instead they
were spending as much as 2third of their
time building databases storage and
compute infrastructure it's easy to see
that this was a big problem Amazon
needed a solution if it didn't find one
it risked squandering the advantage it
works so hard to build an answer arrived
just in time and once again it came in
the form of a classic Amazon memo the
author was a guy named Matt round a
senior engineer who was persistent and
outspoken about how hard it had gotten
to actually build things within Amazon
his memo opened with a bang to many of
us Amazon feels more like a tectonic
plate than an F-16 that's a great Hook
from there Matt set out some principles
for maximizing the amount of time that
Amazon's Engineers spent building cool
things maximizing their autonomy
adoption of rest architectures
standardization of infrastructure
removal of bureaucracy and continuous
deployment if you work in software today
none of those recommendations sound
radical to you but remember this was 20
years ago Matt's memo was probably on
the agenda when Amazon's senior
leadership team gathered at Jeff bezos's
house in Medina for an offsite all the
company's biggest hitters were there
Jeff Bezos obviously it was his house
Andy jasse the CTO Alan veran the CIO
Rick delzell and others they were there
to brain storm new business ideas and
list out Amazon's core strengths they
thought it would take half an hour an
hour tops but as the meeting went on the
people in the room began to realize
something the distributed computing
Manifesto Amazon's migration to S SOA
Amazon launching web services in 2002
and thirdparty developers building more
than 100 applications within 2 years
Matt round's memo these weren't
disperate threads they were all pointing
in the same direction a couple of years
after AWS properly launched Jeff Bezos
gave a talk at why combinator startup
school it was a few years before my time
but people were still talking about it
when I was there it's a good thing and I
mean for all of society that the talk
was recorded I was in Luxembourg and I
took a tour of a 300-year-old
brewery their business of course is
making beer and about a 100 years ago
they were one of the first uh factories
in Luxembourg to start using electric
power to make to help make beer to help
in the manufacturing process and of
course they couldn't buy the electric
power off of the electric grid because
there wasn't an electric grid so they
started making their own electric power
if you could make your operations more
efficient or do new things with electric
power the only way to get power was to
set up your own generator and become an
expert in electric power generation the
important thing to notice here is that
the fact that they generated their own
electric power did not make their beer
taste better and what startup companies
want actually companies of all sizes is
they want to go from their IDE a or
their Vision to a successful product as
quickly as possible the problem always
is that there's a lot of
undifferentiated heavy lifting that gets
in the middle between your idea vision
and that successful product the
undifferentiated heavy lifting by the
way has to be done at worldclass levels
of Excellence or your vision will fail
but it's totally undifferentiated and
isn't actually making the beer taste
better teams inside Amazon had been
spending too much time doing things that
didn't make their beer taste any better
and if that was happening at Amazon then
it must have been happening everywhere
Amazon already offered limited software
tools to developers and businesses
through Amazon web services 1.0 and the
company was already building the digital
infrastructure it needed to run its
expanding operations maybe it was time
to take that infrastructure expertise
and externalize it so other people could
make their beer taste better the idea
for AWS didn't emerge fully formed from
that offsite in 2003 but it was the day
the starting gun was fired we've now
arrived at the part of the story where
Andy jasse wrote his six-page vision
statement for AWS by now you know how
high the stakes were but I haven't
explained what was actually in that memo
to inform his thinking Andy assembled a
tiger team of the 10 best technical
Minds within Amazon and together they
deconstructed the major web services of
the day like Google and eBay they
reflected on their own expertise within
Amazon on Amazon's principles as a
company their target audience their
competitors and the vision emerged the
team came up with a list of Primitives
basic highly flexible Services storage
compute databases and a Content
distribution Network these are the raw
materials of what became AWS the Lego
blocks in other words the team also
decided that in order for AWS to make an
impact it had to be flexible and
scalable it had to be built from the
bottom up and it had to launch with as
many services as possible it wouldn't be
easy but the opportunity was right there
as a result of all that planning and
deliberation Andy's memo didn't just
suggest that Amazon rent out their
unused server capacity he suggested Ed a
pricing model he sketched out Technical
and implementation details it was a
collaboratively produced road map no
wonder the s team was impressed let's go
back to Alan veran because he wrote the
six-page proposal for what became the
first core component of AWS the simple
storage service or S3 for short he wrote
most of it at the six arms a pub in
Seattle and because he had already
contributed a lot to Amazon his ideas
were taken seriously his proposal was
approved and he put together a team to
build it Jeff Bezos was so closely
involved in the development process that
Alan verm Mulin called him the product
manager of S3 he asked questions
suggested ideas and challenged Allan and
his team to think big having Jeff Bezos
as your product manager would be pretty
scary but it showed that he was Allin
Amazon never had to raise any Capital to
build AWS because the company's senior
leaders were committed to the project
and took the time to understand it on
March 14th 2006 Amazon launched S3 S3
stores objects which is just any text
images and other assets that customers
create as part of their normal business
it's a massive disc drive in the cloud
before S3 companies including Amazon
itself were paying way too much for data
storage the old business model created a
tough dilemma for companies that handled
lots of data either you bet on yourself
in which case you needed to spend
massive amounts of money to install
fixed amounts of server capacity or you
set your sites lower spending Less in
the short term but limiting long-term
potential it was a l lose situation so
many businesses either didn't grow as
large as they could have or were never
founded in the first place all because
of data storage costs S3 totally turned
that on its head all of a sudden you
could store data in the cloud and you'd
only pay for what you used you didn't
need to have Deep Pockets to buy space
in S3 you could sign up with an email
address pay with a credit card and get
started that day it was as flexible as
you were and according to Andy jasse it
was informed by what Amazon's customers
were telling them ver Mulan says that
just before he retired from Amazon in
2021 he found the original S3 design
document the growth projections were off
by a factor of thousands within 2 months
the number of objects stored on S3
exceeded Amazon's Expectations by a
factor of 100 6 years after launching S3
had more than a trillion objects in
storage today that number has grown to
over a 100 trillion that's what happens
when you make infinite data storage
convenient and affordable Amazon
disrupted the old business model because
S3 scaled with its customers in effect
it allowed customers to trade upfront
costs for variable costs every business
will make that trade Amazon's margins on
S 3 were never as big as oracles or ibms
but that's fine Amazon had years of
experience dealing with lower margins
from their retail business in addition
to being highly cost-effective the S3
pricing model was optimistic because
when you offer a solution that lets
people focus on making their beer taste
better and encourages other people to
get into the Brewing business some of
them are going to win and when they win
they're going to need a lot more storage
they're going to need a lot more of
everything that requires them to spend
more money and if you take care of them
they'll spend it on you in August of
2006 just a a few months after the
launch of S3 Amazon launched the second
core component of AWS the elastic
compute Cloud also known as ec2 there's
actually some controversy about how ec2
was created the official narrative is
that ec2 or something like it was in the
memo that Andy presented to Amazon's s
team The descenting Narrative is that
the ec2 concept was actually developed
by a guy named Chris Pinkham who is
leading Amazon's network engineering
operations at the time Andy jasse
actually addressed this in his Infamous
one-star review of the book the
everything store when he wrote The
Vision document proposing the AWS
business and outlining the initial set
of services for AWS including our
compute service ec2 was finished and
presented to the executive team in
September of 2003 I wrote the document
and was lucky to have the help of
several people in putting it together
you won't find much mention of Chris
Pinkham in the official AWS story who is
Right does it even matter it matters
because it reminds us that a concept as
disruptive as AWS could only come from
from Amazon itself and it matters
because it's a reminder that the idea is
just a small fraction of the actual work
you've still got to actually build the
product and the business and Chris penum
had left Amazon before ec2 even launched
so what is ec2 it's basically a network
of virtual computers that you can use to
run applications you log in and
configure a virtual machine an instance
it's elastic because a user can create
launch and terminate instances as they
need the same way that S3 blew people's
minds by providing infinite storage at
low cost ec2 provided a way for everyone
to perform intensive computations in the
cloud it was truly revolutionary all of
a sudden you didn't need to spend months
and millions of dollars on data centers
you could create an account and let
Amazon with their unbeatable scale do
the heavy lifting as a value proposition
it was hard to resist at this point it's
important to differentiate between two
types of AWS customers startups and
Enterprises because they both tell
different stories about its massive
success for startups the use case was
immediately obvious lowcost storage and
compute when you needed it if you were
were a developer you could even just
build applications on top of it but
initially there was some skepticism
about whether established Enterprises
would adopt it with the same enthusiasm
even if the status quo wasn't perfect it
seemed like a risk for Enterprises to
lift and shift their storage and data
center operations from what they had
onto AWS enter Netflix we were facing
some extraordinary growth so um
streaming at that point in 2008 was
about a million hours a month and now
it's over a billion hours a month so
we've had this thousandfold old ramp up
in computational resources necessary
over just four years with the ad
basically Broadband networks and
streaming and so you know we had to take
some risks you know doing that kind of
buildout with your own data centers was
going to be challenging um and uh it's
worked out great for us and the key is
that now we're on a cost curve and on an
architecture that you know with as all
of this room does more with AWS we
benefit by that Collective effect that
gets you to scale and brings the prices
down Netflix started out by mailing DVDs
to subscribers but with the opportunity
of streaming ahead of them they realized
they needed to change up their business
model at first Netflix actually
partnered with Microsoft to build out
their video streaming capacity it cost
millions of dollars switching over to
AWS looked risky but Reed Hastings knew
that not switching over was a much
bigger Risk by the time he spoke to Andy
jasse at the first ever reinvent
conference in 2012 95% of Netflix's
computation and storage was in AWS
there's something else worth mentioning
here as AWS was getting better it was
also getting cheaper one of the major
announcements at reinvent was a 28%
reduction in S3 storage costs enabled by
infrastructure upgrades and economies of
scale Amazon didn't really need the
credibility of a customer like Netflix
and it probably wasn't even the first
big Enterprise to switch to AWS but
Netflix switching over showed everyone
that not only did Enterprises have
nothing to fear from AWS they could use
it to become a better company and it
wasn't just Netflix Airbnb launched in
2008 Uber the year after stripe the year
after that all of them are multi-billion
dollar companies none of them would look
the same without AWS today AWS customers
use it for absolutely everything from
Storage development and testing to
Scientific Computing CRM and maintaining
Mission critical Financial systems more
than 15 years after launch ec2 and S3
still form the core of AWS but Amazon's
Engineers never rested on their Laurels
they kept rolling out new features and
they just kept on going in late 2008
they released cloudfront a service that
speeds up delivery of web content
virtual private Cloud a serverless
database service a massive data
warehouse platform with each new AWS
product Amazon was sending a clear
message we're listening to our customers
and squeezing our competitors S3
originally launched with eight
microservices when Amazon's CTO Warner
Vogal took to the stage to deliver the
keynote address at the 2022 reinvent
conference it had more than 235 AWS
doesn't get taken offline for
maintenance in fact outside of a service
disruption in 2011 AWS has pretty much
never gone offline AWS customers never
have to upgrade to a new version because
the service is constantly being updated
all of this goes back to that
fundamental point I made earlier coming
up with the idea of AWS was an
incredible achievement that's worth
studying but actually executing day in
and day out is what's allowed Amazon's
leaders to grow it into the world's most
successful internal startup today you
could easily build an ancestry.com style
family tree of all of the different AWS
services but beyond the different
products and services is an extremely
simple value proposition the reasons we
hear people people moving in the cloud
you get to trade capex or variable
expense that variable expense is lower
than what you can do on your own it
provides you elasticity so you only pay
for what you consume it lets you move
much more quickly it lets you use your
scarce resources of Engineers on things
to differentiate your business and then
you can go Global and provide that
customer experience in minutes or days
as opposed to months the story of how
Amazon built AWS is also the story of
how its Rivals failed the simple version
is that Amazon beat the existing data
storage and database providers by
providing a better product at lower
price and beat Microsoft and Google by
being first to Market there's an
alternate reality where I'm making this
video about Microsoft and it's not too
different from this one because to be
honest Microsoft should have figured out
cloud computing sooner the reason they
didn't was because the company was a
total mess in the Steve Balmer era its
priorities were all wrong Windows teams
had too much power internally so
anything that looked like it could
cannibalize that Revenue stream was
watered down or scrapped entirely
meanwhile Balmer was too focused on
taking down the iPhone he eventually got
with the program and of course SAA Adela
saw the potential of cloud computing
right away but by the time Microsoft
took Azure seriously it was already a
long way behind AWS it's been playing
catchup ever since what about Google the
theory I've read which I agree with is
that basically Google didn't have the
right combination of skills and
incentives internally to see the
opportunity like Amazon did Google
became one of the world's biggest and
most cash generative businesses mostly
through a single product search but it
never really needed to get its hands
dirty its leaders never had to learn to
sell to consumers or Enterprises they
never had to learn how to grow under
tight profit margins so they weren't
really equipped to build a platform like
AWS of course today both Microsoft and
Google do have cloud computing platforms
of their own recent estimates put Azure
at about 20% market share while Google
cloud is at about 10% so they're making
inroads but both companies should have
been competing with AWS years before
they actually did but they were too
distracted by the money they were making
from software and advertising to see the
opportunity Andy jasse talks about this
all the time everyone in Amazon was
stunned that their competitors were so
late to cloud computing AWS ran the
table for years because it was first to
Market and even as real competitors have
emerged Amazon's maintained its
Advantage because AWS is easy use cost
competitive and because it's the default
Choice the numbers around AWS are hard
to comprehend more than half of Amazon's
total operating profits have come from
AWS its Revenue curve is absolutely
insane and if it switched off the lights
on Amazon amazon.com today Amazon
corporate would still have more than a
hundred billion dollar worth of
committed Revenue coming in from AWS but
the true value of what AWS has
accomplished is impossible to capture
and because of that people tend to reach
for analogies AWS is like Lego AWS is
like oil stuff like that but I think
Jeff Bezos nailed it when he spoke at YC
combinator startup School AWS is like
electricity it's a powerful engine for
economic growth and technological
progress in the 21st century it's a
public utility that has enabled the
existence of entirely new types of
companies the app economy SAS companies
modern streaming services none of these
would exist without being built on top
of AWS not only that it's allowed
existing Enterprises like schools Banks
government agencies even Amazon itself
to generate massive amounts of value by
focusing on what they're good at and
through the research I did for this
video I learned something profound only
Amazon could have created AWS when it
did because it was the only company with
a combination of a hard technical
problem to solve an internal culture
that encouraged Ultra smart people to
explore ideas and a Relentless focus on
execution as a result AWS Powers the
modern internet for 15 years it's
basically had a free stake in every
startup and the bigger it gets the
bigger it gets because it can achieve
further economies of scale and continue
lowering prices it's one of the biggest
flywheels ever if I had to put a number
on it I'd say that the total value
created directly by AWS is in the
trillions of dollars at this point which
translates to millions of jobs thousands
of businesses and higher standards of
living for everyone and those numbers
are still going up every single day in
his 2014 letter to Amazon shareholders
Jeff Bezos wrote that for all practical
purposes I believe AWS is Market size
unconstrained the intervening decade has
basically proven him right so when he
stepped down as CEO almost 27 years to
the day after Amazon was founded there
was only one choice for his replacement
his former Shadow the guy who almost
became a sports caster but wound up
leading AWS Andy jasse to learn more
about another company that will Define
the future of computing just watch this
video next thanks a lot